welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boston this is a breakdown of the
opening scene of Marvel's secret
Invasion coming June 21st this was
released on this promotional website The
Invasion has begun.com where you enter a
password in a video Blaze looks like
Marvel's getting very lost Dharma
Initiative here and it's like I was made
for this all these Clues pinned up to a
wall with yarn this is how my office
always looks my wife loves it anyway I
am going to break this down frame by
frame for all the details you might have
missed and please subscribe to the Deep
dive into the break room channels and to
get some more deaths by grabbing
something from nerd Riot that shop like
this Miles Morales Multiverse dive shirt
this video is sponsored by Squarespace
the all-in-one platform that makes
launching your own website a breeze okay
the opening Marvel title card omits the
flashing MCU moments and the Contours
and the Interiors of the letters that we
typically see this might just be a
placeholder for this promo but I just
want to point out for you so let you
know I got my eye on it okay then Moscow
this show is using the same exact title
card location type base as we saw in
Captain America Civil War and in black
widows stylistically and totally the
producers of this series are going for
that spycraft Vibe and this whole idea
of a globe trotting political drama also
notice they say present day which tells
us that a this might not be the opening
scene of the episode there could be a
preceding prologue scene that said even
earlier like maybe the skull's discovery
of Earth in the late 1980s and or B the
MCU doesn't really want to commit on
what the present day year of the MCU
timeline is because there's all kinds of
disagreement from people internally at
Marvel Studios and this is getting
delayed all the time okay then we see
Martin Freeman as Everett Ross I'll be
right there don't move now last time we
saw Everett Ross was in Black Panther
what kind of forever having run afoul of
his ex-wife Val Julie Louis-Dreyfus the
current CIA director of the MCU because
Ross committed Espionage on behalf of
the wakandans that put him in custody
and as he was transported Okoye broke
him free so now he's technically a
fugitive On The Run thus the discreet
knit cap and the scarf Ascot around his
neck notice how Ross tosses this phone
showing how he is using burners and he
just doesn't want to be tracked he's a
good spot then we hear this voice
imagine a world where information can be
trusted not very hard is it this is
Agent Prescott the closed captioning
Spells at Prescott actor Richard Dormer
Eric dondarian the lightning Lord from
Game of Thrones that might be where you
recognize this throaty True Believer
croak his words outline the deeper
themes of the series trust no one or
really who can you trust now I like how
the entity makes it seem like this is
just a general voice over establishing
the theme of all this but the Practical
function of it in the scene is
Prescott's opening pitch to Ross he's
using this rhetorical approach to
convince Ross that the one thing a spy
can normally rely on his relationships
are compromised in this world filled
with scroll shapeshifters Prescott also
might be referring to the fraught
relationship Ross has with his ex-wife
Val and Prescott doesn't know yet that
one of these two or maybe both of them
Ross and Val could be squirrels
themselves they're at the top of my
scroll specialist list now as Ross walks
up to this building you can see the
windows on the second floor are papered
with newspaper to hide from surveillance
and to pin on one's favorite conspiracy
collage we see that in the inside of
this room Prescott screens show
satellite imagery and ukn24 news now
this might be propaganda news coming
from the Kremlin even that propaganda
might tell Prescott some important
information about where the next attack
might be another wall shows headlines
about a Colombian ex-rebel politician a
nationalist seeing a rise in young voter
support after a terrorist attack maybe
this guy is a squirrel puppet politician
who's benefiting from squirrel voters
but beneath that is a CIA classified
document with a bearded assassin's file
photo operation treadstone which might
be a nod to the Black Ops code name from
The Bourne Identity series also three
yellow Post-its Bogota Terror connected
to Heist who is a target beside those on
the printout to the left of it Argentine
group claimed to be responsible so it
sounds like there was a group of
Argentinian terrorists who attacked
Bogota Colombia and then a nationalist
politician in Colombia used that attack
to run on a security campaign to rise in
the polls also benefiting from a
coalition including young voters but all
this was the false flag orchestrated by
the scroll Network to justify a
retribution attack on another country we
see This Global conspiracy on the next
wall close-up reporting a crazed mass
shooting in Munich 26 dead and then on
the right blue Post-its an embassy
attack leading 187 dead holy crap and
between them photos of a plane exploding
and then in the shot of Prescott beneath
the Columbia headlines Prescott has
linked other events in the Philippines
so Prescott narrates where his thinking
is here five Global terrorists strikes
within the past year Argentina attacks
Colombia Colombia attacks the
Philippines so yeah Prescott is right
that it makes no sense for one country
to get an attacks and then to strike
against another country in a completely
different hemisphere because none of
these countries in our world at least
are known for having any kind of
animosity against each other enough to
strike each other with terrorist attacks
now yes we are in the Rave new world of
the MCU which has been completely thrown
Askew by the blip with widespread
homelessness and all kinds of
international insurgents and a big
marveled Celestial in the Indian Ocean
none of this makes sense but I love how
this show is trying to justify it in
some kind of geopolitical conspiracy
because according to Prescott it does
kind of sound like a virus is hopping
from country to Country to destabilize
each part of the globe and draw the
whole world in kind of a cold war but
really a high world war that just
doesn't use nukes why because the
squirrels don't want to to radiate the
planet they're trying to take over
Prescott warns about what will happen
when it reaches the major power and we
know from Trailer footage that there
will be a bombing in the country they're
currently in Russia in moscow's Red
Square it's 2023 if you have a business
you should have a website if you're
gonna have a website you should be using
Squarespace Squarespace is an all-in-one
platform that provides you with
everything you need to do whatever you
need with your website if you're just
getting started you can build your site
using one of squarespace's professional
website templates they have designs for
every category and use case they make it
super easy to customize your look update
content and add features to fit your
unique needs and if one of your needs is
merch Squarespace makes it easy to do
that too you can design your products
and save time and money by letting
Squarespace handle production inventory
and shipping and if you're selling
something besides merch whether that
means physical Goods digital Goods or a
service Squarespace makes it easy to
build your storefront and grow your
business to check it out for yourself
head to squarespace.com for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com new rockstars to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
a domain on the table beside Ross is a
question the translator book seems like
Prescott has been chasing this chaos
country to Country and it's quickly had
to learn the language whenever he lands
somewhere and he says there is an
architect to that tension agent Ross an
architect interesting choice of words
reminding us of the architect and the
Matrix Reloaded The Conspiracy man
behind the curtain then Prescott says
not people
Scrolls and I love it the camera pushes
in and dormer's delivery just great he's
nuts but he also sounds dead serious
like there's a chance this series could
come off as tongue-in-cheek or
self-effacing like many Marvel titles do
but no no not here Prescott says scrolls
with disgust and Terror and we believe
him he gives us some background it
started 30 years ago when the Scrolls
found her Carol Danvers and Nick Fury
promise to find them a new planet but
now now they don't want just any Planet
they want ours yeah he's catching stuff
with the events of the 2019 Captain
Marvel film which ended with Carol
leaving with the Scrolls in 1995 to try
to find a new home world but in
Spider-Man far from home and in one
division we learned that some scrolls
are still hanging out on Earth in
Disguise as various government figures
Prescott asks then where is Fury he's
unsaver yes saber is the name of the
space station where we see Nick Fury in
the trailer for the Marvels which is
coming later this year in the comics the
organization's called Sword and the
space station is called the peak but in
the MCU sword is a security organization
that it's on One Division it seems like
saber is an offshoot of Sword maybe save
your stance for something like Security
Agency border and extraterrestrial
response we'll find out but again Ross
is acting so skeptical and it just seems
sus like he probably knows a lot more
about the Scrolls that he's letting on
or is probably a scroll himself he's at
the top of my list I mean the guy came
out of nowhere in Civil War and he is
exactly the kind of government agent
with ulterior motives who would make
sense to be revealed as a scroll press
got hands Ross a hollow display device
that he claims will set the world on
fire and when Ross switches it on you
can barely see the face of a scroll
appearing at the bottom of a frame but
known as Martin Freeman's eyes Ross
stops looking down at the display he
looks up out unfazed as if he's not
surprised by this supposedly bombshell
update and now when we cut back to Ross
the photo from that device looks like
the face of Kingsley been a deer playing
the squirrel gravic now this might just
be photo evidence of some scroll
shape-shifting into a human oh my God
but both these agents no Scrolls exist
so why would that matter no I think
Graphics human form is somewhat
important to society or someone in the
orbit of another important person just a
reminder of the hierarchy of power right
now in the MCU Dermot Mulroney is
playing U.S president Brits in sounds
like James Rhodes might actually be
secretary of state currently if Thaddeus
Ross in the MCU is gonna be Harrison
Ford it's going to be president in
Captain America Brave New World so that
might make him the current vice
president so this promo ends with
trailer footage that we've mostly seen
before except this clip well mama always
said I was special
mama always said bearing Forrest Gump
Cadence there but there is some
deceptive editing here president britson
isn't in this helicopter that Fury
brings down he's in an SUV that gets hit
this is actually an attack helicopter
that assaulted the motorcade and fury
and Taylor start defending the motorcade
so now that we know that this world is
going to be drawn into war every country
in a kind of armed conflict with each
other everybody confused I think that's
going to directly set up the events of
Captain America Brave New World as Sam
Wilson a new president Thaddeus Ross
square off to claim the banner of
American values in a worldly stabilized
by terrorism and conspiracy theories hey
subscribe to the Deep dive and the
Breakthrough and support us by grabbing
some merch at nerdriot.shop you can
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at
eat a boss follow new rockstars And
subscribe to Newark stars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]